with a foggy-headed marionette in the
oval office i figured now
would be a better time than just about
ever
to give out a definitive ranking of
the presidents you know other people
they'll say this is
s tier and this is f tier we have
different categories for the top
tier the ester we have king arthur the
ideal
leader at the next level right below
that where you can really show you know
you got some
booleans oh the language on you you know
you're really tough maybe you're not
quite the top but you're pretty good
king
leonidas in the third tier kind of
middle of the road
some good stuff but a little bit weak
you've got king mufasa
the level below that now things are
getting pretty bad you have king lear
and then at the lowest tier we of course
have the burger king
level of commander in chief those are
the five categories arthur
leonidas mufasa lear
and burger before we begin this video is
sponsored by
ring no matter your home ring has
everything you need to protect it
more from them in a minute now let's get
started
right i'm going to try going to try to
get through at least half of the
presidents and give them the definitive
ranking let's begin with
numero uno george washington
george washington first president of the
united states no question whatsoever
he is king arthur he may actually be the
reincarnation of king arthur
the indispensable man loved lots of the
founding fathers
he was the best among them without
george washington
there would not be a united states of
america i'm pretty confident to say
so he's the one he gets the top spot no
surprise there
next up john adams the second president
of the united states
he was less commanding perhaps than
george washington
but he was still really really great i'm
going to give him
leonidas okay he's right right below
that top tier
like leonidas he lost right so he won he
won one term but then he lost to thomas
jefferson
in the election of 1800 the other thing
i really like about john adams
other than he was a conservative and a
real conservative you know he defended
the british
soldiers in the boston massacre because
he felt that they were in the right
and that the the way the press had been
covering this was was not fair but then
of course he was one of the great
patriots in the revolution so
really fair-minded very conservative he
had an acid tongue he once
said of alexander hamilton who was a
member of adam's own party
that uh he he was the braster bat of a
scotch peddler
and there there were not enough [ __ ]
in philadelphia to contain his super
abundance of secretions
so that's you know that's pretty
terrific addiction he'll get that
leonidas level next up thomas jefferson
the man who beat john adams
i'm going to give jefferson he gets
leonidas too
he's not quite king arthur because some
of his ideas were a little kooky
but this is the this is also the reason
why jefferson gets such a high ranking
is he talked like a big lib if you read
a lot of what jefferson wrote
he really sounded kind of like a a lib
however he behaved in many ways like a
conservative
he expanded the united states he was a
great defender of liberal education
liberal in the good sense of that word
even though he did he kind of weakened
it a little bit found at the university
of virginia
all around really really impressive guy
so okay he's up there with leonidas
andrew jackson seventh president of the
united states
everyone wants me to say burger king
level
or at the you know very best he's a
mufasa type
or a king lear no
andrew jackson also gets leonidas level
i know
they're going to call me a racist or a
sexist or this sister or that is oh
he andrew jackson he was mean to the
indians or something which frankly was
actually his
successor who was far meaner to the
indians but let's not forget
andrew jackson fought wars he was a war
hero not just against the indians
but against the british he was the hero
of new orleans when it comes to the
indian wars by the way for the people
who want to say that he was a big racist
or something like that he actually
adopted an
indian child who had been orphaned so i
don't think he had harbored any kind of
personal bigotry
he was a man of and for the people
demonstrated great courage
he was also against the kind of
bureaucratized government the
professional administrative class he was
really against that
had a little bit of populism i think
this is why trump liked jackson so much
so i don't care he founded the democrat
party okay whatever that's fine he still
gets leonidas tear
for me he pursued necessary national
policies and had the courage to do it
next up
william henry harrison most people don't
think about that name
harrison was the shortest presidency
that we've ever had
harrison was president for exactly one
month
uh so he you know he can't be king
arthur he didn't make it that long he
can't be leonidas
really but i'll give him gosh should i
give him leonidas too
no that's that's a little too much i'll
give him mufasa
he's that kind of mufasa tier the reason
i really like him though
is first of all he's the hero of tip
canoe he was a good good strong american
military leader
and he didn't like that he was being
insulted on the campaign trail
he didn't like the people were saying
he'd lost a step or two so
for his inauguration he went out
and it was a rainy cold day and he gave
a two hour long speech
and they had already trimmed it down to
give a two hour long speech
in the cold and in the rain he then
attended multiple inauguration parties
and he just went out he really did it up
and then he took sick and he died
shortly thereafter
but you got to give him credit for the
gumption a lot of courage so good good
on him
next up abraham lincoln 16th president
of the united states he
is the only president i think who could
vie
with washington for that king arthur
level because his mind was so capacious
he was he was such a symbol of the
american
dream the american idea a guy rose up
from nothing
very serious had studied shakespeare in
the king james bible that was
what what made up the bulk of his
education
he did try toward nobility
throughout his entire life and where he
fell
short you know he at least was always
trying he was really striving for
self-improvement
held the country together and in that
sense refounded the nation after the
civil war so
he gets up there with king arthur next
up james garfield
20th president of the united states
everybody forgets james garfield
he also died shortly after he was
brought into office he died i think he
was assassinated
could be wrong about that he might have
just taken sick and died but anyway
that's not why i'm interested
in garfield garfield i guess would get
a mufasa level he wasn't wasn't super
duper impressive
except that he published the first
blank book in american history the
magnificent
this was called the political
achievements and statesmanship of
general hancock
regular democratic nominee for president
it was five blank pages the first blank
book in american history
was republicans trolling democrats in
the 1880 presidential election
for that alone he has to at least rank
you know in that middle tier if not a
little bit higher
next up the vice president to
james garfield who became president upon
his death who published the second
blank book in american history in the
next presidential election that would be
chester a arthur
a highly highly underrated president
chester arthur had a very strong record
he was he was good on matters of
civil rights he was he was a relatively
modest president he was relatively
humble republicans right now by the way
can learn something from chester arthur
in the way that he handled the
immigration question you know
republicans
have this thing where we want to have
national borders we want to control who
gets to come into the country
we want there to be national unity of
course every country wants to do that
but in the united states if you say
that you want to enforce very basic laws
of immigration
you're called a racist that's right and
chester arthur there was a big
immigration law that came up
during his presidency in 1882 and he
vetoed the first version of the bill
because he felt that it would have would
have been punitive and violated violated
some treaties
and so he sent it back and then there
was another bill that came to his desk
which was you know a little bit
more moderate in its immigration
policies and he signed that one as well
so you can be tough on it
without you know falling into bigotry or
racism or something like that
it was moderate moderation is a virtue
but it was strong in the sense that
it did enforce national borders and
you know assimilate new immigrants who
would come in
and and maintain that national unity
great stuff chester arthur he doesn't he
does not get enough credit
people forget about him but he really
did a good job took over after
after up but i guess i'll put him i'll
put him at mufasa level two some
interesting reforms under him next up
grover cleveland
i'm not saying i love grover cleveland
he was a big dem but he has the
distinction of being
the 22nd and the 24th president
he's the only president who won
non-consecutive terms
so good on him for that you got to give
him some credit he's at least
he's at least a mufasa i think he no
we'll give him a mufasa there's a you
want to give him that that leonidas
because it was just so tough that he
went
and got that second term but i'll give
him the mufasa level
and then we get to very possibly the
worst president
in the history of the united states
woodrow wilson
28th president woodrow wilson only
became president by the way because
teddy roosevelt
wanted to come back into power so he
split the conservatives who would have
been
voting for his successor taft and that
by splitting the right
gave woodrow wilson a way to enter the
white house and destroy our country
wilson is the most consciously
progressive president
in american history he said that the old
constitutional government is outdated
it's based on the laws of isaac newton
and a fixed universe and permanent human
nature so you got to ditch all that
we're living in the age of darwin baby
everything's evolving we're using the
power of rock and roll to change the
world
we need to let government bureaucrats
just run the whole country absent
any accountability to the people he just
ruined everything just about
everyone always goes after wilson for
being a racist like sure that's bad
you know but when you consider the list
of the horrible things this guy did
i don't even know if it's on the first
three pages that's how bad
his his presidency was uh he's going to
be king lear
the reason he's not all the way down at
burger king is because
he really did die kind of mad and
furious and ripping his hair out
because finally after he had almost
thoroughly destroyed the country
the the senate refused to go along with
his stupid
united or at that time the league of
nations plan so they wouldn't sign on to
it and he was really upset by that and
he died from the stress so you know kind
of like leary's just screaming and
yelling blow
wind crack your cheeks next up
warren harding oh warren harding you
know that guy's at least a mufasa
he is everyone thinks he's a burger king
everyone says oh harding he's
one of the worst presidents in american
history very very
underrated president when he died in
office he was one of the most popular
presidents in the history of the country
he was really strong on various
matters you know he like how do i put
this i sound like i'm donald trump he
was really strong
and the thing you know the thing they
always try to hit him on teapot dome
this was the scandal for for harding
that
uh you know uh there was some moderate
sort of corruption that was just a way
to distract her he had a very
good record he was very popular he was
serving the interests of the people he
was a modest reformer
i give him mufasa next up calvin
coolidge silent cal
last of his breed gotta love
silent cal i would put him at
i put him at a leonidas level the reason
i put him at a leonidas level
is he was so deferential to the american
tradition he was so reverent toward
george washington he was so modest in
his own personal comportment
he really stood firm with this changing
tide where you were going to get
more and more of a sort of aggressive
celebrity presidency stood firm against
that
silent cal he's good only president ever
shrinked the government next up
franklin roosevelt 32nd president of the
united states
this one kills me because
on the one hand he's the most effective
president we've ever had he was a king
he he made himself a king
whereas someone like calvin coolidge
would rather leave
office than stay in office longer than
george washington roosevelt he wanted to
stay there four terms he would have
stayed there longer had he not died
roosevelt just utterly upending the the
country
implementing the sort of government that
woodrow wilson had designed
so he was ruthlessly effective but it
was all bad
so sh is he should he rank really high
up on the list or really low i'm gonna
put him really low
he is the burger king not because he was
a joke not because he was incompetent
burger king is a very successful company
but because it was not uh he was no king
arthur let's put it that way
no king arthur in his castle
you know a man is the king of his own
castle if you want to keep your castle
secure you gotta check out ring
no matter your home ring has everything
you need to protect it see and speak to
whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells keep an eye on
every corner of your house with easy to
install indoor and outdoor cameras
protect your whole home with ring alarm
a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself right now
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ring.com
knowles that's right ring.com knowles
i really love ring because if i'm
traveling i know that sweet little elise
and my wife and cute little june my son
will be safe knowing that they can know
who is outside the door before
they open that door you know sometimes
it's food delivery oh that's great
sometimes it's
a package delivery toys that's very nice
sometimes it's the in-laws and you want
to stay perfectly
perfectly still head on over to ring.com
knowles canada w-l-e-s ring dot com
slash knowles next up dwight
d eisenhower he was a republican
he was a war hero but he was kind of a
lib let's
get busy this is the problem this is
really tough so i guess
i'd give him mufasa level maybe his
heart was in the right place maybe he
was he was trying
to do good stuff but he ultimately was
not particularly
successful he in many ways accelerated
the liberalization of america this is
why william f buckley jr when he when he
founded the sort of postwar conservative
movement
he was pretty cool to ike they wanted a
more conservative candidate
eisenhower much more from the liberal
wing of the party on the flip side of
that you have john f kennedy
john f kennedy was from the more
conservative wing anti-communist swing
of the democratic party now i'm not one
of these people that idolizes kennedy
i you know he is fine he wasn't
president for very long i like your
funny words magic man
i would probably rank him though at a
leonidas level
the the reason i would put him at
leonidas is you know he was a lib and in
his personal life he was a bit of a
degenerate
but he was a staunch
anti-communist he loved joseph mccarthy
actually john f kennedy's brother robert
kennedy
went to joe mccarthy's funeral that's
how much the kennedys loved mccarthy it
was the most
toughest anti-communist crusader we had
so i gave him leonidas for that
and then unfortunately the communists
took him out next up is lbj
lbj also he's another one like fdr
lbj 36th president pushed through the
the
great society radically upended our
culture
and our political system really in in a
way sort of refounded the country in
terms of the
legal and political upheavals during his
his reign
so very very effective great amassing
power
if you read the biography of of lbj by
robert carro
you see that this guy is as dishonest as
they come
this guy was stealing elections back in
college he stole an election for his
little
staff club when he was working on the
hill he certainly stole that 1948 senate
election in texas which is how he then
became senator vice president and then
president after kennedy died
so the effect of lbj pretty
weak stuff i would put him at the lear
level because also by the time he ran
for re-election he
wanted to run for re-election he
couldn't he just the popularity was not
there
next up richard nixon richard nixon is a
tragic case because in many ways he was
a terrific
president he was one of the great
political figures of his age
nixon always wins
he was basically the only person who
believed whitaker chambers when whitaker
chambers said that there are
commies in the government up to
including alger hiss
who helped found the u.n at the state
department guys like harry dexter white
at treasury
everyone said oh you're crazy this is
conspiratorial no way all the libs tried
to downplay it but no there were commies
throughout the us government who were
who were taking direct orders from
moscow and who were who were serving as
soviet spies
so nixon knew it he caught it they never
forgave him for it
they never forgave him for taking down
alger hiss that's why there were so many
shenanigans in 1960 and that's why the
deep state stole the election from him
or rather stole the presidency from him
after he won re-election
later on however nixon
let his paranoia run away with him he
made some crucial political mistakes
and he went down because of it i'm not
saying it was fair but he probably went
down a little bit like king lear
uh too bad because if if not for that i
i
you know i'm torn he's either a king
lear or leonidas
he's one of the two it just depends on
kind of what part of his career you're
going to focus on
so you know what because i want to take
a more positive view of nixon i'll give
him the leonidas thing
but he did go down so in some ways he's
kind of like king lear make of that what
you will
jimmy carter burger king
done that's it it's easy ronald reagan
reagan
uh 40th president of the united states
really terrific he's a leonidas
he's not quite a king arthur i love
reagan he's not quite a king arthur but
he was great he
he understood what was going on he stood
firm he won the cold war
he had a clear view of the world his
legacy has been tarnished by a bunch of
squishes who
pretend to speak for him and they call
themselves reaganites but they're not
really
reagan was a lot tougher than people
give him credit for next up george h.w
bush
he's mufasa i guess
i'm being generous i think to george h.w
bush you know he he was an
admirable guy he lived an admirable life
he was from the liberal wing of the
republican party but
upright guy who just at the end of the
cold war
when he could have gone really been
really tough
when he could have really focused on the
challenges that we had
he basically embraced a kind of liberal
internationalism
so the cold war had roiled the united
states for
the latter part of the 20th century we
win it reagan wins it the berlin wall
comes down
and george h.w bush instead of focusing
on the the cultural
new cold war that was going on in the
united states he decided to look abroad
and
famously you saw this one in the 1992
republican nominating convention
there were two candidates pat buchanan
who was the social conservative
and george h.w bush who was the liberal
republican and in the speeches
buchanan gave the famous culture war
speech which i talk about in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
and george h.w bush talked about how the
real fight now is to just make a lot of
money
and we need to control the markets
around the world so we made some more
money and we lost the whole culture it's
too bad
bill clinton was basically just a
continuation
of george h.w bush they were both
liberal centrist internationalists
there's not not much
not much of a difference between them i
guess clinton was more of a degenerate
in his personal life
and had creative uses for cigars and
things like that i did not
have sexual relations with that woman
but uh you know i put him i don't know
what's he
i guess he's sort of like a mufasa in
this i mean no he's a burger king he's a
clown right bill clinton's just a clown
and and won't really be remembered for
for much of anything because he didn't
even
even ask what did he stand for he stood
for his own pleasure basically
george w bush poor guy he he actually i
do think had some beliefs
but he just was not not very effective
and he kind of got rolled by a lot of
people and
and so he was upright in his personal
comportment but but in terms of the
efficacy of his presidency he was pretty
weak stuff he's a mufasa
barack obama obama was effective
he really was effective and so in that
sense you know in a way
you want to give him credit for being a
big tough guy but but
because of how bad the the effect of his
policies were in the country
you got to make a burger king then we
get to donald trump the best president
of my lifetime i haven't been around
very long but he you'd i'd call him a
leonidas
he's not he's not a king arthur
he's got he's got some personal issues
he would be the first one to tell you
that but he did fight really hard he
fought for a good cause
and he lost like leonidas he was
ultimately
unsuccessful but he put up a good fight
i think he inspired a lot of people i
hope that
you know like leonidas loses at the
battle of thermopylae but the greeks win
the war
about a year later hopefully you know
trump they went after him they went
after him he fended them off you know
repeatedly
but then you know in the end ultimately
they finally got him but hopefully he
can
inspire the rest of us conservatives to
win the longer war
then finally joe biden joe bide
is there another tier can i have a t i
don't even want to give him credit for
being burger king
i think that the burger king stands for
much more than joe biden does
and i think the burger king is in much
greater control of his corporation
than joe biden isn't in control of the
country come on man
so he's some he's some lower tier he's
some lesser fast food
restaurant so what could be
below burger king i guess i guess joe
biden he's more of a jack-in-the-box
he is i don't i don't want to offend
jack-in-the-box fans out there i think
their burgers actually taste better than
burger king
but he's not he's not a full king joe
biden he is
a marionette he is just a sort of
cloudy-minded marionette b and the
strings are being pulled broadly by the
liberal establishment
so he sadly is just a jack-in-the-box uh
if you agree with my rankings
be sure to let me know in the comment
section hit that like and subscribe
button
and be sure to post what you want me to
rank next see you next time
you